there's this proud moment in every
content creator's life when their
creative offspring head out on their own
channel adventures and don't need papa
cinemasins anymore well that don't you
forget we're all started and get your
ass back over to cinemasins before dark
damn kids
[Music]
for always in it marvel's probably
earned this 35 second self-indulgent
clip cophany of logos the problem is now
everyone thinks they can do it sega
releases one halfway decent video game
franchise and it's like look at our
glorious undulating mountains of ip slow
your roll choo choo rocket no one's here
for you based on the last episode
steven's aware that he's getting up
somehow and going places even with being
chained to the bed so why is he still
bothering with it why are these
restraints yeah of course not show only
uses the mirror thing when it's
convenient for the plot also who has a
mirror on a wall with a door you have to
open to get to the mirror not saying
these types of mirror installments don't
exist but why why is this mirror do not
tell donna that i let you into
this arena you mean the arena that's
wide open to anyone who strolls by that
arena this is the surveillance
equivalent of having your password for
everything be the word password what
you're about to see
is going to melt your brain no what's
melting my brain is that you never tell
him which camera or a specific time yet
he always finds the correct footage
clearly discount dax shepard is in on it
bruv it's like area 51 like
mi6 bonkers brother calling people bruv
also how's this like either of those
things steven mentioned steven was
chased by the ghost of an egyptian
jackal and gave himself over to the guy
living inside his head and turned into a
superhero shouldn't he say it's more
like a superhero thing or a [ __ ] eld
thing even if we find out this series
doesn't take place in the mcu proper
they still have [ __ ] comic books in
this world don't they i'm just saying
area 51 and mi6 don't cover these kinds
of predicaments watch here it comes
suspect asks someone to look at security
video to prove his or her innocence and
it ends up just making them look more
guilty cliche what are you doing you
donut thinking calling someone a tasty
and delicious treat is an insult am i
supposed to despise stephen i want to
eat him larry and maintenance is going
to absolutely
hilarion maintenance has a name ass hat
it's well it's larry i guess he did say
his name and i overreacted hmm this is
awkward look a cyclops desktop water
fountains it's the equivalent of having
an open container next to all the
equipment on your desk why would you do
that you you raspberry danish yeah so he
still doesn't work i know this is a
classic hr to say but
are you not alone i know this is classic
tv since to say but this classic hr goes
on for all the some time this table's
had hands on it and mugs and pamphlets
slid across it yet somehow it looks as
if the glass is so clean that you can
see your reflection in it clearly enough
to ponder if your american doppelganger
personality might pop out for a bit to
say hi oh mate thank you oh thanks
cheers hugging discount shirley eaton
and making them break character when
their one job is to stay completely
still you can't go into someone's job
and destroy what they're known for come
on marvel do people come into your
environment and direct competent action
scenes i'm looking for my stories locker
it's under steven grant if it's not
understanding grant it might be on the
mark this works of course i know you
number 43 right and yet you let him him
and off for a full minute before saying
anything because apparently the show
still hasn't got enough of the oscar
isaac limey time yet
this is a terrible lighting system these
lights are apparently motion activated
extremely dim only stay on for a few
seconds while walking by and make an
extremely loud noise each time they turn
on or off it's almost like the system
was designed for maximum creepiness not
the ability to actually light a room and
now these metal walls are polished so
well they offer a perfect reflection
look around you right now how many
non-mirror crystal clear reflections of
yourself do you see if the answer's
north of zero my apologies you may
actually be a moon knight i'd say you're
a compass
but you're not pointing those you said
holy [ __ ] nuggets this scarab is
magically floating wrong also what about
it's floating makes you think it's a
compass i mean it is a compass but i
think you only know that because you
read it in the script hello man in the
mirror
i was wondering if you'd pop up again
talking to the man in the mirror you
know maybe stephen will make a change
for once in his life my hair feels real
good you can make a difference you can
make it right look i don't care
how bloody handsome you are he looks
just like you he's more confident than
whatever this pommy needs his mommy
routine is sure but what a weird thing
to say to a person who looks exactly
like you look marvel i don't come to you
for genuinely creepy and vibey horror
thriller content i'm here for
superheroes cracking jokes and talking
about thanos so stop it with this
well-produced genre okay
freeze frames what is this moon night
from the files of the police squad mark
where have you been conveniently falling
directly in front of your motorcycle so
we can move on to the next part of the
plot you feels like i'm riding with a
victorian duchess that's duchess did you
see the spiral you put me through i'd
give all the sins back if we find out
this movie's in the saw universe and
chris rock shows up to work out a
routine for his next gig at caroline's
stop with the accent please from your
lips to conscious ears layla she
shouldn't be here setting aside the
continued convenient reflection is
convenient [ __ ] steven isn't even
over here or likely visible in that
tank's reflection he's still by the door
so can the other personalities just
appear at random in any mirror anywhere
now can oscar isaac watch me in the
shower no seriously can he no no sorry i
wasn't talking to you but steven knows
this is how he'll come off right this is
not the first time he's been caught
talking to himself and he already knows
she doesn't believe any of his story
about not being mark no this is my mom's
flat living in your mom's flat as an
adult and if you think that's petty
welcome to the channel hope you stick
around a while occasionally there's a
smell of cinnamon buns it's a candle and
not actually cinnamon buns but it's
still really nice i promise she's my
favorite part
um no she's my favorite jeez guys more
than one person can love a thing i knew
toxic fandom started with marceline
disboard valmore i just knew it who
never divorced you you just discovered
you were married to her stephen i know
you were worried about the unilateral
comment being creepy but this is way
creepier for the record if mark is
really trying to get stephen to stop
showing her this stuff why is he doing
it from this tiny shaving mirror instead
of gloria's fish tank reflection from
earlier and how does she even hear him i
need about 20 minutes of exposition on
all the rules of the mirror universe and
if you think it's too complicated feel
free to get margo robbie in a bubble
bath to explain it you're gonna get her
killed you hear me maybe start with that
line of approach next time mark and then
steven never even mentions the bag
because at this point she's gonna find
out what's in there for the sake of her
own curiosity you already don't remember
why we've been looking for this no but i
do remember for the last 10 minutes or
so layla's been insistent on how much
she doesn't believe steven's claims and
now all of a sudden for no reason she
does i've vandalized the toilet
referring to the entirety of the
restroom as the toilet or just simply
british people let's just give two sins
to make sure we've covered all our bases
what's this
it's a paperweight i mean everything's a
paperweight if you try hard enough is
there any bigger symbol of our own
incest need to commercialize everything
that we have a category of items
designed to hold down paper i thought we
were going to the police station nope
these two are with gaduca's vincent
freeman who despite having plentiful
resources coming out of his sarcophagus
sack decided to wait 24 hours and then
send a couple of lackeys to pick him up
instead of you know grabbing him last
night he was probably stuck at the
museum because he didn't save anything
for the uber back do you hear me
i hear you loud and clear steven grant
of the gift shop that's a walkie-talkie
a walkie-talkie stephen was not pressing
down on when he was talking to mark in
the rearview mirror so harrow shouldn't
have been able to hear anything steven
was saying episode doesn't know how to
walkie-talkie correctly let's get you
out of those cuffs that's nice and all
but our heroine is called gonna tend to
steven's concussion as well that he
almost certainly got from hitting the
pavement when he fell out of that car
that's right that's why i'm here
to help oh i see we've reached the part
in every modern villain story where the
villain tries to convince the
protagonist and the audience that
they're actually good even though no one
will buy it and they will be proven to
be a psychopath shortly thereafter see
this neighborhood used to have the
highest crime rate in all the city
now
people don't lock their doors at night
they feel safe zentrification oh chase
are those the tomatoes over emphasizing
the when asking about the tomatoes
they're just tomatoes unless they give
you super strength or four hour erection
there's no need to emphasize anything
about them it's victor's recipe ignoring
the guard rails and sitting on a
crumbling artifice you're smarter than
that victor ahmed knows this too well
she tears evil up from the root casting
our judgment before any evil's done
minority report don't you do it do not
give lil up he's been sitting there by
this ultra reflective bull this whole
time and you wait until harrow's done
his entire [ __ ] monologue to pipe in
having that much bread right next to you
and not eating any of it i don't care if
it's not vegan-friendly bread look at
how scrumptious it all is eat the bread
stephen eat the [ __ ] bread sometimes
to cure her
it's a little
taste of the disease [ __ ] the cure
is the cure the cure is the solution the
cure is a new wave banned from west
sussex how do these idiots have these
terrible sayings ready to go at any
moment is there a villain soup for the
soul book i need to know about the child
is not a diseased limb this is true
disease limbs don't cry all the time
when they don't get their way crash a
car in a snowstorm because it just had
to have fruity pebbles or force you to
take out a second mortgage to get them a
four-year degree in philosophy some
people might even call a disease limb a
blessing in comparison do you know what
this is yup
it's okay yeah steven grant of the gift
shop would be the moon nightiest at tv
sins where's the scarab i haven't
what but why why is she here why would
she bring it even if she thought she
needed to save steven and did she track
his phone here did they let him keep it
and how did she get all the way in here
without being noticed or stopped or
frisked this entrance is dumb on a
motive level a practical level and a
character level also it's really nice we
have such a strong female co-lead in
this episode whose soul character trait
seems to be she's very convenient and
has great dramatic timing yay
moon knight i really do love the shows
using egyptian deities as the antagonist
but could we have gone with a look for
konshu that was slightly more commanding
than a scooby-doo villain summon the
suit roll communicates so then shackle's
been bumping into that door for the last
minute or so and it just opens now was
he messing with the doorknob knocking
gently building tension while stephen
once again makes the idiotic decision to
not give mark the body as it's written
into the script it's great that the suit
helped him survive this but what helped
him survive this from the moment stephen
cliches his three-point landing to the
time the jackal jumps on him he has a
minute long repartee with this
conveniently placed mirror mark was the
jackal just chilling up above waiting
for his queue i did it you got planted
scene of me finally getting my vegetable
garden under control somehow makes it
into the episode do you reckon he's
having a seizure
he's just a fancy drunk in what city
does being fancy including latex white
head and face covering this the eyes
wide shut universe please let it be the
eyes wide shut universe well this whole
rooftop chase is absolutely badass i'm
only human guys and honestly i'm just
glad the show has finally decided to do
some moon knighting but also bruce
willis and civil shepherd are not making
a tv show called moon knighting in this
scene
sorry
we've always managed to keep a wall
between us but something's changed i'm
pretty sure the something that has
changed is that the story needs mark to
do some now pursuing seven years of bad
luck this aggressively
needing to see the pyramids this
aggressively
i'm here to see your butt i'm standing
here you make a move
you make a move
it's your move
are you crying why are you crying
there's no crying how long am i waiting
different angle yeah
different
you look a little nervous
first time holding a gun hello man in
the mirror this was your idea george
it's a good idea right it's a good idea
monogamy is sexual slavery
tell me what it is you are
what are you
you sure you want to know yes daddy yes
i'm batman you want my body
right yeah mark how about this for a
deal you've got the body
i've got the brain
it's not okay yeah i'm still your wife
uh my wife stop with the accent please
that's how i talk isn't that a bit dodgy
like trusting the judgment of a weird
crocodile lady strange women lying in
ponds distributing swords there's no
basis for a system of government